as the holidays approach Americans
batten down the hatches for a brutal
week of coronavirus numbers doctors and
politicians bat around solutions and
President Trump and Joe Biden go at it
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored
by expressive VPN surf the web with
peace of mind signed up right now and
Express at VPN calm / balance expressvpn
dot-com
/ memo I hope that you had a wonderful
relaxing weekend which was exactly the
same as your weeks I know I mean it is
it is incredible how all the days just
sort of meld into one another
particularly you have children then
there is no day we are all just living
one long day that is all that is
happening right now
just the longest day and this is
supposed to be the longest week and
pretty much everybody is in agreement
that this week is going to be very very
bad in terms of the coronavirus numbers
we've seen over a thousand deaths most
of those in New York City over the
course of the last three or four days
our current corona virus account right
now is well over it's well over nine
thousand deaths are there have we
surpassed ten thousand deaths in the
United States at this point if not that
we will today the United States is
standing as of yesterday at 96 hundred
seventy nine dots there were about 1,100
to 1,200 deaths yesterday in the United
States from coronavirus there's a little
bit of good news and that is if you look
at some of the models that are being
used here they're being revised downward
so the the model that comes from
University of Washington that's the
model the Maryam the so called Murray
model that was being used by the White
House that model has now been revised up
in terms of peak and down in terms of
duration which is overall not a horrible
thing given the fact that they've
actually lowered their death estimate
fairly tremendously over the last four
days last week I read to you from the
model and they said they're gonna be
about ninety four thousand deaths in the
United States by August 1st 2020 now
they are suggesting there will be 82,000
Kovan 19 deaths by August 4th 2020 now
what's amazing about that modelling is
which factors are changing right what
exactly is changing it's hard to tell so
it is not that people are staying home
more that was already taken into account
in the model so what it is suggesting is
that it's raging like wildfire where
it's raging and then after that it stops
raging and the
is the estimate that is being put
forward not by me but by a scientist
over at East Anglia University he's
suggesting that people have been under
estimating how fast this thing is going
to burn and the good news on that is
that you're going to see it burn out
more quickly according to the scientists
at East Anglia University which by the
way University of East Anglia in Britain
is one of the places that the left loves
to cite with regard to climate change
models so this is not some fly-by-night
organization say many of the models
being used to forecast the Cova 19
epidemic give poor predictions of both
the epidemics peak and its duration
according to an academic at the
University of East Anglia comparison of
a new approach with a published model of
kovat 19 in wuhan before isolation and
social distancing measures were imposed
shows that the standard model
underestimates the peak infection rate
by a factor of 3 meaning it will be
three times higher and substantially
overestimates how long the epidemic will
continue after the peak in other words
it rages through the population and then
it seems to sort of stop and that is why
you are seeing the models change in real
time
the model that's being used the Murray
model has been wrong on a wide variety
of basis so for example as of yesterday
so yesterday was what April 6th so
yesterday they were expecting there
would be 98 thousand beds across the
United States that would be needed
hospital beds needed from Coben 19 the
same day the estimate that was being put
forward by the CDC was somewhere on the
order of forty thousand beds so the
number of beds estimated was actually
significantly lower than the number of
beds that actually were needed I mean
then the number estimate was much higher
than the number that were actually
needed when it came to ICU beds as of
yesterday the the AMA Qi study from
University of Washington was suggesting
that there would be nineteen thousand
three hundred and sixteen beds needed
that was as of yesterday but the number
of people who are actually in critical
condition according to the Johns Hopkins
statistics the number of people in
critical in the United States is
significantly lower than that the number
of critical is like eighty seven hundred
so you assume that most of the people in
critical virtually all of them
presumably aren't into baiters are on
are on the the I'm sorry ventilators
their intubated for ventilators the
number of people in critical right now
is 8700 so that is an order of to lower
than the number of people who are
expected to be on ventilators if we are
getting complete information so that
doesn't suggest that this thing isn't
really virulent and really terrible it
does suggest that these models are going
to be
constantly updated and they need to be
constantly updated because the fact is
that if they are not constantly updated
then they're getting it wrong that's not
a problem with how the models work it is
a problem with taking the models
incomplete face value which is what I
was saying last week as a Friday that
nobody was giving me inputs nobody was
giving me outputs nobody's giving the
amount of time nobody was explaining
whether there was going to be a second
wave in the fall if there is going to be
a second wave in the fall how is that
going to be prevented if there's gonna
be a second wave in the fall maybe the
best thing that we can do is just
increase the number of ICU beds and
ventilators and then put everybody who's
over the age of 65 with a pre-existing
health condition under warning and say
to them you need to basically stay
indoors by the way by the data the
number of people who are dying are still
largely over the age of 65
we don't have an average age from the
CDC we do know that virtually everybody
who's being hospitalized has a
pre-existing condition and nearly
everybody who is dying has some sort of
pre-existing condition one of the
problems is the government has not been
forthcoming with the data as to what the
average age of people are what are their
actual pre-existing health conditions
right this is a question I get a lot and
if I have high blood pressure and I am
just on a statin does that count as a
pre-existing health condition or if I
have sleep apnea is that a pre-existing
health like what what exactly is a
pre-existing health condition there are
certain pre-existing health conditions
that you know are more likely to land
you in the hospital if you've got a
kidney condition for example that is
much more likely to land you in the
hospital if you have a pre-existing lung
condition or if you have asthma or if
you have a or if you have lung cancer or
something if you have an immunological
problem that's more likely to land you
in the hospital but the government has
not been supremely forthcoming with all
of this so there's a lot of play in the
stats and I want to get back to this
because this really is the point we
cannot make plans for the future until
we have the stats until we have the data
and this has led to this really
interesting philosophical and political
impasse where there's certain people
saying well the data aren't in and we
are destroying twenty eight million jobs
over the course of three weeks for the
sake of data that we don't have and the
other side saying well yeah but if an
asteroid is headed for Earth then we
have to shut everything down until we
have more data now the happy medium of
those positions is okay how about we
shut everything down temporarily until
we have the data and then we ramp up the
data right now right the data is what we
need and as we will see this is the
solution that is now being proposed by a
wide variety of people ranging from
Scott Gottlieb over at the
FTA to business leaders all around the
country who by the way if they're so
selfish why are they so eager to save
40,000 jobs a hundred thousand jobs a
120 thousand two hundred thousand jobs
in their company the people who are the
most active in the sphere in terms of
public health and testing are the member
are the people running major
corporations then that employ tens and
hundreds of thousands of people right
those are the people who are kept up
most at night by this because they
recognize how many lives are on the line
we can get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the
reality of the fact that you are online
right now and that means that malware is
a supreme threat malware is a really bad
threat and it's constantly morphing you
can download a download some of the
antivirus programs on your computer and
they're just not that good because
they're only updated like once every
three years and that means that as these
viruses change online they can grab your
data they can want one of the things
that they've been doing is actually
walking you out and taking hostage your
own data what they'll do is they'll
actually hack your computer and then the
malware will lock you out of your data
unless you pay a ransom it's called
ransomware
well there's a better solution than
going in downloading some crappy free
antivirus thing for your computer
instead what you need is actual security
software from PC Matic it's a whitelist
next generation antivirus designed to
stop modern threats like ransomware
independent testing from av-test
just named PC Matic as a top performer
in the cybersecurity industry giving it
the best performance award for 2019 and
against a whitelist right not a
blacklist traditional security software
relies on a blacklist of no malware but
that list is always changing PC Matic is
that whitelist next generation antivirus
PC maddox competition is made in foreign
countries many where the viruses
originates and the viruses come from
there like hey we have a program for you
to stop the virus how nice
PC Matic however is made in the United
States of blacks annoying of malicious
ads for hassle-free web browsing makes
your computer faster and more reliable
even after years of use of ever had
malware on your computer it's just a
nightmare get PC manic and prevent it
from happening right now
PC Matic is just 50 bucks for five
devices for one year which is really not
a lot of money to pay for the security
of knowing that you're not going to have
malware on your computer and have to
take it down to the stress with a full
30-day money-back guarantee
if you act right now PC Matic has
offered my listeners a free month of
security protection with the purchase of
an annual license to access the offer
head on over to PC manic comm slash Ben
that's PC Maddock comm slash Ben again
at that
world-class security that keeps your
computer's running great go to PC Matic
comm slash then I love it it's on my
computer now I've started using it it
keeps me safe and I really appreciate
that alrighty so back to some of the
some of the information about the
modeling so when it comes to how we
model this sort of stuff there's a few
statistics that we absolutely need that
we don't actually have right now and
they can only be achieved if we go heavy
on the data right that's it right now
our number one priority other than just
increasing ICU beds and ventilators and
making sure the people who need the care
to get the care should be the randomized
testing it should be developing a
serology test that can tell us how many
people actually have this thing that's
gonna wildly change your strategy what
if 50% of the American population
already has this thing right 50% of the
American population already has this
thing then you kind of just want people
to go back to work because then if they
infect a few more people you get hurt
immunity right if only 10% of the
American population has this thing maybe
that changes your strategy in the other
direction or maybe you look at the
infection rates at versus the death
rates and you say okay well the death
rates are actually not that high so we
need to protect the most vulnerable and
just assume that everybody's gonna get
it over the course of the year right all
of these questions cannot be answered
absent the data so as I've discussed
before when it comes to the case
fatality rate when it comes to how many
people are dying from this and how
communicable it is we don't know the
actual numerator there's an article in
The Wall Street Journal today talking
specifically about the fact that we
actually don't know how many people have
died from this thing right we still are
unclear on exactly how bad this thing
could be actually New York Times reports
the u.s. is under country under Counting
the number of people who have died in
the pandemic according to experts quote
hospital officials public health experts
of medical examiners say official
tallies of Americans said to have died
in the pandemic do not capture the
overall number of virus related deaths
leaving the public with limited
understanding of the outbreaks true toll
limited resources in a patchwork of
decision making from one state or county
to the next have contributed to the
undercount
with no uniform system for reporting
coronavirus related deaths in the united
states and continuing shortage of tests
some states and counties have improvised
obfuscated and at times backtracked in
counting the dead
adding to the complications different
jurisdictions are using distinct
standards for tributing a death to the
corona virus and in some cases relying
on techniques that would lower the
overall count of fatalities
so people are dying we're not actually
testing them after they are dead also
it's possible that we misidentified some
people as having influenza or having
pneumonia at the same time it's possible
that we're reclassifying in the other
direction people who normally died of
the flu for example do you classify them
if they're 85 and they died after
acquiring pneumonia after having the flu
did they die of pneumonia at the flu or
old age right how you classify deaths
actually makes a fairly large-scale
difference in what these numbers look
like if somebody is 91 and they pass
away from shortness of breath and then
afterward they are tested for
coronavirus did they die from
coronavirus or did they die of the fact
that they were extremely vulnerable to
begin with now normally we wouldn't
bother testing those people but right
now we are testing it so it's possible
that we are under counting it's also
possible that we are over counting by
comparison with past with with past
death rates meaning that yeah people are
dying of coronavirus but we are being
very meticulous and overly meticulous
maybe in how we count the coronavirus
stats as compared to past counting's of
deaths all right so the numerator is in
Contra is in controversy when we talk
about how many people have actually died
then you have to worry about the
denominator and that's the one I've been
focused on how do we know how many
people have been infected right you are
seeing the case fatality rate in the
case fatality rate is how many people
who are diagnosed with having this thing
died and right now in the United States
the case fatality rate as of over the
weekend was something we have like 9600
people who have died in the United
States and we have as a total number of
infections total cases 338 thousand
eight hundred and 99 so just typing this
into the two computer what you get is
basically the case fatality rate in the
United States is somewhere in the order
of 2.5% which sounds super duper high
the problem is a lot of people are
asymptomatic a lot of people are not
coming into the hospital the people who
are coming in for the testing are the
people with the most severe symptoms so
what exactly is the case fatality rate
case fatality rate is a bad measure in
fact number of cases identified as a bad
measure hospitalizations is a better
measure because it actually means an
actual hard fact how many people are
going to the hospital but the
denominator is in question
so the numerator how many people dead is
in question the denominator how many
people actually have this thing is in
question and then we actually don't know
how the virus is spread because you're
hearing everything from if
somebody breathes on you within a
15-mile radius you're gonna die right or
you could be just walking along the
street and you slip and your hand
touches a pole and suddenly there's
coronavirus on your hand you wipe your
mouth and you're dead right so it's we
just don't know exactly how well this
thing is spread best available data
seems to suggest that you're basically
okay unless someone costs directly in
your face and you're within six feet or
unless you are wiping your face
constantly for taking your hands and
putting them on your face constantly so
if you hand wash a lot and you don't
touch your face your chances of getting
this thing are extraordinarily low
almost someone spits or costs directly
in your face one of the one of the bad
cases of an outbreak actually happened
in a choir practice in Washington State
the reason being at a choir practice
what is everybody doing right everybody
is projecting everybody is singing very
very loudly they're spitting right
that's that's like you should see my
screen after the show right there's
there's a lot of there's a lot of saliva
on the screen now because when you
project over the course of three hours
what you end up with is having to wipe
down your screen well if you're singing
in a crowded area that's probably so all
of this will lead to better methods but
what we need right now is knowing
exactly how this is done first of all
better reporting methods from the states
and localities we need to know how many
people are actually dead of coronavirus
and how that is how those numbers are
reached we have to fix the denominator
right we now have apparently approved
and verified antibody tests we could get
randomized antibody tests and that would
tell you how many people have already
had it right so if you combine antibody
tests with with the actual coronavirus
test and you did it in a randomized
sample size you could actually tell how
far how fast this thing is spreading
particularly in urban areas and they're
saying these antibody tests are pretty
good they're saying about 95 percent
effective by the way it's a lot more
effective than the actual virus test the
actual virus test apparently have like a
20% false positive rate or a false
negative rate which is really insane you
could go in with coronavirus take a test
they tell you're all good to go you go
home and you infect your entire family
so that would tell you exactly once you
have the denominator number then you can
actually tell what what are the
hospitalization rates versus the overall
number and it's based on that number
that people are now making projections
as to how many ICU beds and ventilators
are gonna be Nate are gonna be needed
all right let's say right now that
Andrew Cuomo Governor Cuomo in New York
is saying
then he needs 30,000 ventilators right
that he desperately needs 30,000
ventilators and he is calculating that
by looking at the case fatality rate and
he's saying that's the entire that's the
entirety of everybody who's been
infected so we have 300 let's say that
in New York State we have I can actually
check the statistic really quickly as to
how many people have been confirmed to
have corona virus in the state of New
York in New York that number at the
moment according again to the Johns
Hopkins modelling and and reporting they
say there are about 120 thousand cases
in New York and they have had a grand
total of 4159 deaths right so let's say
that how many people are in New York
State what's the total population of New
York population of New York is the total
population of New York state is 8.6 mm
well that's this is that the city that's
the city New York State the total
population of New York State is 20
million is about 20 million so you
figure one hundred and twenty thousand
people have been confirmed to have this
thing in a state of 20 million people
the case fatality rate right now is is
approximately four you have a 4,100 over
a hundred and twenty three thousand so
the case fatality rate in New York City
in New York State right now is about
three point three percent so if you
figure three point three percent times
twenty million then what you end up with
is a need for you know tens and tens and
tens of thousands of ventilators already
figured that everybody who died needed a
ventilator so if that case fatality rate
is twenty million times point zero three
then you are talking about a need for
six hundred thousand beds probably okay
so he's figuring that not everybody is
going to get it still if if you figured
that only the people who are tested for
the ones we're gonna get it you're gonna
end up with this extraordinarily
high-end estimate for how many beds and
ventilators you need but what if that
statistic isn't showing that tons of
people in New York have already had this
thing then you could actually lower the
number of beds and ventilators that are
necessary and it doesn't look like
30,000 instead it looks like a lot lower
than that right if you knew that the
true number of New Yorkers infected is
already twenty times higher than the
number of people who they think are
infected well that would completely
lower the number of ventilators and beds
you need so all of this data is super
important and the government needs to do
it now we need larger scale antibody
testing when
large scale serology we need large-scale
baseline coronavirus testing and
randomized across the country so we
actually can do it like polling right we
actually need it in different places in
the country so we can tell how fast this
thing is spreading and we need to know
this stuff yesterday right and and
you're starting to see that this call is
going out from pretty much everybody
again
Bill Gates has been suggesting that he
thinks actually that fewer people then
the models show are going to die because
he thinks that we're being pretty
successful at quote-unquote flattening
the curve here was Bill Gates yesterday
saying that well we all need to stay
home the outbreak you know he thinks
don't get worse but it doesn't mean that
the numbers are gonna be as bad as we've
been led to believe if we continue
countrywide and we're testing the right
people to understand what's going on
which it's not the case yet those
numbers will start to go down and then
we can look at some degree of opening
back up president Trump's top health
advisors are talking about somewhere
between a hundred and two hundred forty
thousand deaths over the next two months
does that sound about right to you in
terms of the lethality and the length of
the outbreak here in the US well if we
do the social distancing properly we
should be able to get out of this with
the death number well short of that
okay now Gates has been calling for this
ten weeks shut down but the truth is
that Gates isn't the one paying the
economic price on that on a personal
level I mean his company obviously is
just like all major companies are we all
want to get out of this thing as fast as
possible I would hope and that means
that you need all of this testing ASAP
okay we can get to some of these
methodologies and what this week is
supposed to look like we'll get to all
of that in just one second let's talk
about the fact that you are sitting at
home right now looking at those walls
and thinking man I wish I had a little
bit nicer artwork or maybe you're
looking to get an amazing gift for your
parents for example like now be a great
time to show your parents how much you
care here is a fantastic gift for them
I'm talking about paint your life paint
your life calm with everything going on
right now it's difficult to know if
you're gonna be with your mom for
Mother's Day but if you're looking for a
great way to feel connected to your
loved ones here's a great thing you can
do go to paint your life's icon you get
a professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price
any picture of yourself your kids your
family a special place a cherished pet
you can even combine photos as well you
pick your artist you work with the
artist until it looks absolutely awesome
mother's day is may 10th order before
Easter like make it happen in the next
couple of weeks it is a great gift it
comes directly to you can do it all
online and I mean you want to do
something that really makes sense for
your mom or your dad they're in
quarantine right and you're all locked
down right now is a great time to do
this you can make all the art better in
your house but you can also make it
better for your parents it's a great
great gift for your parents at painter
life's Calm there is no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded guaranteed we have a
painting of my wife me two of our three
children gonna have to do a new one now
because we have a new baby and I can't
wait to do it at paint your life they do
an amazing job you get 20% off right now
you're painting 20% off plus free
shipping when you text the word been to
64,000 texts been to 64000
been to 64,000 paint your life celebrate
the moments that matter most paint your
life calm what a fantastic gift and what
a nice thing you can do for somebody at
a time of year when everybody is kind of
down go check it out right now paint
your life context Ben 264 thousand for
that special 20% off deal okay so where
are things going to go in the near
future well as I say is being bent right
there is some good news right there is
there are some news out of Italy that it
looks like they may have already hit
their height the dow has jumped pretty
significantly this morning and thanks to
news that people may be looking at
different countries coming out of this
thing apparently the the situation in
italy is starting to look a hell of a
lot better according to reuters italy
reported its lowest daily köppen 19
death toll for more than two weeks on
sunday as authorities began to look
ahead to a second phase of the battle
against the new coronavirus once the
lockdown imposed almost a month ago is
eventually eased the toll from the
world's deadliest outbreak reached
15,000 887 which is a quarter of the
global death toll but the rise of 525
from a day earlier was the smallest
daily increase since March 19th then of
patients in badly stretched intensive
care units fell for a second day running
Silvio Bruce a Pharaoh the head of the
Easter tutto superiority Suneetha
Italy's top health institute I'm sure I
botched that says the curve has reached
a plateau plateau and begun to descend
it is a result that we have to achieve
day after day
says if this is true we need to start
thinking about a second phase and keep
down the spread of the disease so you're
starting to see that in Italy you're
starting to see that in France
apparently you're starting to see it in
Spain as well meanwhile in Great Britain
in bad news Boris Johnson the Prime
Minister has been hospitalized now they
say that that is more precautionary than
anything else he's the Prime Minister
and so they want to make sure that he is
is has all of the the needs that he has
at his disposal that's actually led
Queen Elizabeth to speak there's only a
fourth time she's given a public speech
in her entire career so it shows you how
severe the folks in the British
government think this is here is Queen
Elizabeth basically telling everybody to
hold it together I hope in the years to
come
everyone will be able to take pride in
how they responded to this challenge and
those who come after us will say the
Britons of this generation were as
strong as any that the attributes of
self-discipline of quiet good-humoured
resolve and a fellow feeling still
characterized this country the pride in
who we are is not a part of our past
it defines our present and our future
you gotta love her she's terrific
you gotta love the Brits and obviously
everybody's saying prayers for Boris
Johnson for everybody who is suffering
under this epidemic now in in Japan they
are worried about a critical situation
and they mate declare an emergency as
early as Tuesday the early news from
Japan once they'd held this thing down
well but again a hotspot can can rage
this thing out of control fairly quickly
we'll bring you all the news from New
York and from the White House in just
one second first however let us talk
about the fact that right now if your
car is having trouble I have something
that's an absolute godsend for you is
Rock Auto calm right now do you really
want to be walking into stores and
having conversations about auto parts or
would you prefer to sit at home and just
get that auto part put in your economy
good to go
The Rock Auto calm catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate rockauto.com
has everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps of
motor oil even new carpet whether it's
for classic or daily driver get
everything you need in a few easy clicks
delivered directly to your door
rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
the market will bear like the airline's
do there's no reason to spend up to
twice as much for the same part for
example the Delphi FG 1456 fuel pump
assembly for the 2005 2010 Honda Odyssey
will cost you like 354 bucks and advance
which is a big chain store it'll only
cost you 217 bucks at rockauto.com Rock
Auto is a family business and they serve
Auto Parts customers they've been doing
it online for 20 years head on over to
Rock Auto calm right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know we sent you
that is Rock Auto comm see all those
parts right shapiro and their how to
appear how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sent you okay so the
prediction in the united states of
course this is gonna be a really bad
week president Trump over the weekend he
said there is going to be a lot of death
of this week in some cases were telling
governor's we can't go there because we
don't think you need it and we think
someplace else needs it then pretty much
so far we've been right about that and
we'll continue to do it as it really
gets this will be probably the toughest
week between this week and next week
then there'll be a lot of death
unfortunately but a lot less depth death
and if this wasn't done but there will
be death well Anthony foul she says the
same thing he says this is indeed going
to be a very bad week and and of course
these projections will see how bad the
actual death tolls are do they match up
with the projections right the
projection from that from that
University of Washington model that I
spoke about before which says higher
peak but but lesser duration they
suggest that 10 days away there will be
about over 3,000 Americans will die in
one day according to that data in New
York however they're suggesting that as
early as Thursday there will be a
pinnacle in New York City and that
that's what Andrew Cuomo has suggested
he says there will be 878 deaths that
day of course we'll see how the models
hold up in the midst of all of this here
is the here's Anthony pouchy suggesting
that this will indeed be very bad week
well this is going to be a bad week
Margaret unfortunately if you look at
the projection of the curves of the
kinetics of the curves we're going to
continue to see an escalation also we
should hope that within a week maybe a
little bit more we'll start to see a
flattening out of the curve and coming
down
the mitigation that we're talking about
that you just mentioned is absolutely
key to the success of that so on the one
hand things are gonna get bad and we
need to be prepared for that it is going
to be shocking to some Surgeon General
Jerome Adam said the same thing he's
compared this week to 911 or Pearl
Harbor suggesting that Americans are
going to see mass death and really bad
numbers and again those are the best
available studies that is the suggestion
we will see you know how long the
duration is or whether the numbers end
up looking exactly like that University
of Washington which by the way I will
say overall again has been reduced down
from 94 thousand dead by Auggie I mean
it's hard to say these are good numbers
because they're not but has been reduced
down from 94 thousand dead expected by
the beginning of August to 81 thousand
dead and that happened just over the
course of the weekend here's the Surgeon
General
well it's tragically fitting that we're
talking at the beginning of Holy Week
because this is going to be the hardest
and the saddest week of most Americans
lives quite frankly this is going to be
our Pearl Harbor moment our 9/11 moment
only it's not going to be localized it's
going to be happening all over the
country and I want America to understand
that but I also want them to understand
that the public along with the state and
the federal government have the power to
change the trajectory of this epidemic
meanwhile states are suggesting and they
are running low on supplies across the
board that has to be top priority is
making sure that the states get those
those supplies again the whole purpose
of flattening the curve is to get it
underneath that line here's Andrew Cuomo
the governor of New York suggesting that
they are running short on supplies
across the board although he did say
that they're not sure on hospital beds
right he was asked about hospital beds
he said we don't have a problem with
hospital beds we do have a problem that
I see using we have a problem with
ventilators we're running short on
supplies all across the board some
hospitals happen to have a greater
supply of one thing or another one
Hospital has a greater supply of masks
one Hospital has a greater supply of
gowns and when we're talking about
supply hospitals they're accustomed to
dealing with 60 day supply 90 day supply
we're talking about two or three or four
day supply which makes the entire
hospital system uncomfortable which I
also understand because we're literally
going day-to-day with our supplies with
our staff
etc the Louisiana Governor has said the
same thing as well by the way John bel
Edwards he says we could run out of
ventilators this week every day we get
new information that informs our
modeling we now think it's probably
around the 9th of April before we exceed
our ventilator capacity based on the
current number on hand and that we're a
couple of days behind that on ICU bed
capacity being exceeded so as we achieve
success and slowing the rate of spread
we also push out that date and and
critically important is the number of
people who will present at to the
hospital and not be able to get a vent
or a bed is a smaller number okay
meanwhile the economy obviously has been
taken completely offline according to
The Wall Street Journal we've actually
seen one quarter of the entire American
economy taken offline simply by the
state shutdowns they say at least one
quarter of the US economy has suddenly
gone idle amid the corona virus pandemic
according to analysis conducted by The
Wall Street Journal an unprecedented
shutdown of Commerce that economists say
has never occurred on such a wide scale
eight out of ten US counties are under
lockdown orders this represents nearly
96 percent of national output the study
was done by Moody's Analytics the
counties that have not been put under
shutdown order tend to be the ones that
are less urban a little bit more rural
41 states have ordered at least some
businesses to close to reduce the spread
of coronavirus according to Moody's
restaurants universities gyms movie
theaters public parks boutiques millions
of other non-essential business quote
unquote non-essential businesses have
shut off the lights as a result and we
have seen one loss of the estimate is 25
percent of the American economy right
off the top the unemployment statistics
are absolutely astounding we are
expected to hit 28 million unemployed
over the course of the next three to
four weeks and then the question becomes
ok when can we all go back to work right
that is the big question I suggested
early on that we are going to know the
answer to that when we have more data
and once we have that data in then we
started off too we're gonna have to
start making trade-offs and calculations
that is the reality of the situation
right right now basically the case for
us all staying home is asteroid headed
for Earth could kill 2.2 million
Americans based on that Imperial College
model right that is that that was the
the initial estimate and so the idea was
ok if we have to shut down for a month
to prevent 1 in 150 Americans from dying
then let's go ahead and do that but as
more data pours in and as the numbers
show that they are significantly less
than 2.2 million write it look we are
going to have to figure out exactly how
what we are willing to sacrifice as a
society on an economic level and on a
lifestyle level and on a freedom level
because freedom does matter by the way
right mean let's put this in a slightly
different way if the United States were
invaded and the people who are invading
we're going to suggest that from now on
you are not able to go to public events
and you're going to be confined to your
home for the foreseeable future and it
was going to cost us a certain number of
lives and our prevent that invasion what
number of lives would you actually
sacrifice in order to do that now this
is not that because again the hope is
that we don't end up in that situation
the hope is that this is not indefinite
that this is actually quite definite and
as the data comes in that's why we have
to have a plan to get out of this
because the more it looks indefinite the
more it looks like we're gonna have to
make hard trade-offs right now this is
why you need to gather data because you
don't want to have to make those choices
between how many lives we have to
sacrifice and how many people can we
allow to go back to work and leave their
lifestyle and go out and and be free in
a free society you don't want to have to
make those calculations and so the first
priority of the Trump administration
aside from just ensuring that whatever
ventilators are out there to get to the
right places the first priority is the
data and if governors and states and the
federal government are not prioritizing
the data it's because they don't care
enough about your freedoms ok the data
are key absolutely key we'll get to more
of this in just one second because look
we all know the government the
government has to do when it comes to
mobilizing the resources we're all on
the same page here the question is how
we get out of this thing now and how we
make the calculations as to how we get
out of this thing right so now I'm back
where I was on Friday where I was saying
we don't have the data to know how to
get out of this thing they better come
up with it forthwith because as this
thing begins to look indefinite as this
begins to look like okay we're gonna
lock down indefinitely until a vaccine
is developed next year and it could be
seasonal when it comes back in the fall
we're gonna lock back down and what does
an omlette down America even look like
more and more Americans are gonna say
hold up a second you expect me wouldn't
definitely give up my freedom and you
expect me to do that on the basis of
what now and how many wives and from
whom because by the way that does make a
difference every life matters but on an
economic level somebody passing away at
the age of 95 is not quite the same
thing as somebody passing away at the
age of 20 if this were striking children
I think the amount of panic in
it should be eight times the amount of
panic that exists right now and there's
a fair amount of panic right now and to
pretend by the way that these
calculations don't go on on a daily
basis by the government is just silly
literally every public policy
professional makes these sorts of
calculations on an economic GDP level
and on a lifestyle level because
economics is a real-life factor for
those who don't believe that I suggest
that you hand out your bank account
number right now and then we'll see if
the economy actually affects you or not
right public bank account number and
your PIN and then we'll see if you think
that economics is real or if it's just a
social construct I'll get some more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that it's hard to come by
sleep these days I have a brand-new baby
I have two other kids they've been sick
actually over the course the last three
settings I'm not getting enough sleep
when I do sleep I want to be on my Helix
leave mattress because it is made just
for me it's like a cloud created just
for me Hewett sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you whether
you're a side sleeper a hot sleeper
whether you like a pleasure from bed
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine and CNN called it the
most comfortable mattress they've ever
slept on head on over to helix sleep
comm slash men take their two minutes
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty you have to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free don't even pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
indeed you will why because it's made
just for you what's not to love he looks
right now is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders for our listeners and up
to 200 bucks off at helix sleep comm
slash man that is helix sleep comm slash
man go check them out right now helix
sleep calm slash Ben take the two-minute
quiz my wife and I have the mattress is
fantastic again get 200 bucks off at
helix sleep calm slash up Ben alrighty
in just one second we are going to get
to more of the proposed solutions plus
President Trump going at it with the
media when it comes to politics the real
question is going to become how much of
this is permanent and how much of this
is temporary because conservatives slash
libertarians like me even I am willing
to go along with the temporary I am not
willing to go along with permanent and
I'm not willing to go along with the
idea that we're gonna radically
transform America's economy our
relationship with the government on the
basis of uncertain data
I mean I'll let you have the period of
time to get your data together guys I'm
willing to trust the experts until you
get the data together
but you can't keep kicking it down the
road you can't keep telling me it'll
take you six months to gather the data
because at that point you're looking at
the making permanence of things that
were once temporary I understand the
idea of temporary most people do in the
middle of a war people make sacrifices
but that's what the understanding of the
war eventually ends war never ends
people are gonna start rethinking that
stuff pretty damn fast there we can get
some more of this in just one second
because this does implicate some broader
conversations about the future of the
country and where we go from here if you
haven't had a chance to see some of our
new content called the all-access live
you should head over to daily where to
come and check it out Jeremy boring and
I kicked it off a few weeks ago oh the
other hosts have done live streams over
at Daley wire.com we're gonna continue
all this week at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m.
Pacific
all access live it's a lot more relaxed
than our normal programming it is less
focused on bringing you news and
information more about sitting down with
you at the end of a long day and just
hanging out with you I'm gonna be doing
at least one of these this week head on
over to all-access live right now at
Daley we're calm all of our members get
to check it out right now because we all
want to just hang out together we're all
stuck in our houses anyway go check us
out at Daley wire.com if you're around
at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific to
join us on all access live you're
listening to the largest growing fastest
and fastest growing conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
so as Scott Gottlieb is saying one of
the other solutions that needs to be
brought to bear here is not just ICU
beds and ventilators but new but new
treatments Gottlieb says some imagine
coronavirus will run its tragic course
in the spring with the direct the
diverse results avoided by intense
social distancing and then our lives can
more or less return to normal he says
that's not realistic
even if new cases start to stall in the
summer heat the virus will then return
in the fall so the fresh risk of large
outbreaks and even a new epidemic people
will still be reluctant to crowd into
stores restaurants or arenas schools may
remain closed the public's fears won't
relent simply because there are fewer
new cases we'll be running an 80%
economy he says the only way out is with
technology aggressive surveillance and
screening can help warn of new infection
clusters that could turn into outbreaks
but that won't be enough a vaccine could
beat the virus there won't be one this
year then I the best near-term hope is
an effective therapeutic drug that would
be transformative it's plausible as soon
as this summer but the process will have
to move faster there are a few different
possibilities
dozens of promising antiviral drugs has
Gottlieb Zahra Gottlieb are in various
stages of development could be advanced
quickly the one furthest along is at
REMS a severe from Gilead Sciences there
is evidence from clinical experience
with kovat 19 patients it could be
effective the other approach involves
antibody drugs which mimic the function
of immune cells antibody drugs are based
on the same scientific principles that
make convalescent plasma one interim
tactic for treating at the sickest kovat
19 patients the biotech company
Regeneron
successfully developed an antibody drug
to treat Ebola as well as one against
Mears and they're working on one that
could hit human trials as soon as June
but we're gonna need to see all of this
speed up also
there's talk about hydroxychloroquine
the media again trying to generate all
sorts of controversy about this anthony
found she apparently got in a big
argument with the with the head of trade
Peter Navarro who again like I'm not
sure what he has to say about
hydroxychloroquine foul she correctly
says that the data is anecdotal at this
point and people are upset without you
for saying that
the data can be anecdotal and also it
might be the best option we have both of
those things could be true right just
because there's been no large-scale
clinical trial in very small-scale
clinical trials just because there's
been no large-scale clinical trial does
not mean that when people are losing
lung function they're gonna sit around
going oh well you know I think that
maybe I need to
trial before you give me the
hydroxychloroquine like that's not how
any of this is working again the
measures that have to be taken ICU beds
ventilators new drugs developed and then
the question becomes if that's not going
to happen by the fall how do we reopen
the economy right the question right now
is not why there is no everyone's
focused on the here and now I get it
everybody is focused on should we have a
national lock down order should we
batten down the hatches like totally
right now and the answer is I don't
think so on the national lock down order
because every area of the United States
is different and I'm not gonna treat a
rural area the same that I would treat
in a urban area they're not quite the
same and they're not quite the same and
the level of transmission from one world
to urban right now is actually fairly
low I saw this bizarre map that somebody
was was putting out the other day about
the distances from their homes that
people were driving and in the south
people are driving longer distances away
from their homes the suggestion being
that they were going and like visit what
were they going and spitting on people I
got that I went for a drive with my kids
yesterday we probably drove for 45
minutes so what we didn't get out of the
car doesn't mean that we're going around
infecting people with all of that said
the priority has to be reopening the
economy as soon as we have the data to
suggest exactly how we make that happen
so here's President Trump over the
weekend again getting bashed for this he
says we have to reopen our economy it
doesn't matter of course it matters
and anybody who pretends it doesn't
matter is really making me suspicious at
this point Trump is not saying when we
reopen our economy Trump is not saying
that we're gonna reopen our economy
tomorrow he is saying that he has to
have that first and foremost in his mind
by the way one of the reasons why he is
saying this is because on the back of
every crisis there is an attempt to
radically transform America this
happened in the aftermath of the Great
Depression a radical transformation in
the lives of Americans between the
relationship between government federal
state local and human beings this
happened in the aftermath of 9/11 with
regard to our security right suddenly
people were just willing to accept a lot
more surveillance in their lives than
ever they had been willing to accept
before and now they're starting to
backtrack that right now people like oh
well maybe that wasn't such a great idea
in the aftermath of every crisis there
is an attempt to radically grow
government on a permanent level and that
there's just a normal human response
because you want to prevent the bad
thing from happening again well in this
case where you have the largest
government reaction in the history of
the United States
the pot the prospect of that being made
into a permanent feature of the American
landscape is pretty scary and it's one
of the reasons why we should be looking
to get out of this as fast as humanly
possible let me give you an example so
Andrew yang right my boy Andrew yeah I
like Andrew right Andrews a really good
guy he was promoting universal basic
income like two like years ago right he
comes on the Sunday special we have a
full hour-long conversation and the case
that Andrew is making is that technology
is gonna put every low-wage worker out
of work and so we have to provide a
universal basic income for those people
so they had something to live on and I
said to him at the time there's not a
lot of evidence this is happening right
we have a we have a four percent
unemployment rate in the country we have
more jobs open then there are people to
fill those jobs we do not have this vast
underclass of people who are
unemployable or unemployed in fact wages
were rising fastest for people at the
bottom in terms of blue-collar wages as
a percentage they're rising very quickly
for people at the bottom under president
interim presidency up until this point
now you have this vast shutdown nearly
everybody who's losing their job is
somebody who's in blue collar job right
somebody who's earning not a lot of
money people who work at restaurants
people who are people who are working in
domestic industries people who are
working at hotels right all those people
are out of work right now
you just threw thirty million people out
of work of those thirty million people
probably 25 million of those people were
low lower wage mid to low wage or lower
income workers so you just accomplished
what in in literally a week when Andrew
yang was predicting was going to happen
over the course of ten years okay so if
you don't want to see a vast underclass
of Americans who are just supported
purely by the government you need this
economy up and running fast and not only
that you need people to rely on
capitalism you need people to get back
to the model of yeah capitalism is great
it's what allows me to work it's what
allows me to get out there and earn what
you don't want is the government coming
in forcibly shutting down the entire
economy throwing thirty million people
out of work and then all those people
have no choice but to vote for bigger
governments they have no choice but to
vote for a government that's gonna fill
the gap created by the government in the
first place right I'm willing I've been
willing to go along this whole time with
the government drives that Ford f-150
through the front wall of your house now
they gotta repay you for that that's
fine but what if the government just
leaves the Ford f-150 there what if the
damage done by the Ford f-150 is so
grave to the front wall of your home
that the government isn't gonna offer
you a repayment
to rebuild your home they're not gonna
allow you to rebuild your home in fact
because the economy's been stalled for
too long and and because they need these
temporary shutdowns then become
permanent shutdowns and so instead what
they say is okay we're gonna put you up
in government housing sorry I'm gonna
have to move out of that house that we
wrecked but we've got this really nice
housing tenement in the project and
you're gonna have to go there and people
say okay well I have no alternative so I
guess I get I'm going to have to take
that right that is the danger here is
that people start to radically rethink
capitalism even though it wasn't
capitalism they failed here what failed
here was it was a global health shock
followed by heavy government action and
if that becomes permanent that is a real
danger and so I am not willing to allow
that to become permanent I'm not willing
to allow the government to become the
chief breadwinner for all Americans and
do so off the back of the people who are
going to be left in the economy earning
now when the government created this
situation in the first place
I'm not willing to allow that to happen
on a long-term basis again on a
short-term basis sometimes you got to do
what you got to do all right sometimes
you got to shut down the school
sometimes you gotta shut although I
think there are serious questions as to
whether that should have been done
sometimes you have to you have to shut
things down because we don't have any
other better data but if it turns out
that the data gathering is taking a year
and this is becoming a permanent feature
and that the idea is that we are now
going to be levying wealth taxes on
people and destroying entrepreneurial
activity in this country and destroying
every business in the country on the
basis of we threw thirty forty fifty
million people out of work and the only
place you can get the wealth cuz we
can't sell our bonds anymore because
nobody is buying bonds the only way to
raise the money is either inflation or
to confiscate wealth from the people who
are going to produce all of them us
products and hire all of these people
back that's a radical reach effed okay
so Trump is not wrong when he says we
have to reopen the economy he is exactly
right this is correct we will continue
to use every power every authority every
single resource we've got to keep our
people healthy safe secure and to get
this thing over with we want to finish
this war we have to get back to work we
have to get we have to open our country
again we have to open our country again
we don't want to be doing this for
months and months and months with an
open our country again this country
wasn't meant for this few were and
president Trump continues he says the
Cure can't be worse than the problem and
he's getting all sorts of flak va's I
don't understand how this is even
remotely controversial of course the
Cure can't be worse than the problem the
question is how Bad's the problem gonna
be and we don't know yet right once we
know how bad the problem is gonna be
then we know whether the cure is worse
than the problem right if you won't go
into the doctor's office and you say
listen I've been having some shortness
of breath and the doctor says okay well
I'm gonna need to put you on an
anti-malarial drug and we're gonna
ventilate you and you're like well hold
on you didn't even give me a corona
virus test yet I don't even know like
what what are you saying now is the Cure
worse than the problem who the hell
knows we don't know the scope of the
problem it could be he just had an
asthma attack it could be that you got
code that you got Kovac right until we
know the scope of the problem it's hard
to say whether the cure is worse than
the problem here's President from saying
the care can't be worse than the problem
which of course is true get the data get
the data this is on the Trump
administration get the data I want to
see antibody tests all over the country
randomized antibody tests all over the
country we need randomized coronavirus
tests all over the country you're
telling me that we're gonna be able to
roll out 750 thousand tests every week
and you can't spare 10,000 of those
tests for just a randomized kanda mised
polling sample or that you can't open up
a data center where we actually learn
what the conditions are of people who
are dying from this thing better data
better data better data you don't want
to care to be worse than the problem we
got to identify the problem you can do
it fast it doesn't take that long here's
President Trump saying the Cure can't be
worse than the problem we have to open
our country you know I I had an
expression the Cure can't be worse than
the problem itself right I started by
saying that and I continue to say it the
Cure cannot be worse than the problem
itself we got to get our country open ok
President Trump also says that he wants
fans back in the arenas which is true
and then he's asked specific like the
media are they they want they want Trump
- it's amazing the same time they're
saying the Trump is completely
incompetent horrible at everything
they're like but what if you took
everything over I could you make that
happen
I mean why don't you just nationalize
the industries why are you just an issue
of national lockdown and Trump's like we
have something called the Constitution
I'll tell you
I'm gonna let from say this and then I'm
gonna point something out which should
frighten everybody okay here's President
Trump talking about the Constitution we
have a thing called the Constitution
which I cherish number one number two
those governors I know every one of them
that doing a great job they're being
very very successful in what they're
doing and as you know I want the
governor's to be running things now in
some cases will supersede but in this
case it's not I think it depends it
depends on the individual state that
you're talking about but they're doing
very well and they're doing a
magnificent job in running their states
okay so you know he is not wrong about
this I mean a lot of these states are
doing a good job and you know Rhonda
Sanchez has been dragged over the coals
because we're on his hands the governor
of Florida State wide shut down there
were shutdowns in place for three of the
biggest counties in in Florida I mean
that that's that's a reality that's true
okay so it's so here's here's the thing
that should scare you if a Democrat were
in charge right now there's been a lot
of talk about the political divide in
the country if a Democrat were in charge
right now and using this as an
opportunity to make permanent all of
this stuff the amount of blowback would
be intense
the only reason there has not been the
amount of blowback from Republican
States that I think he would see if a
Democrat were president is because
people have the basic idea that Trump
does not actually want the consequences
of this stuff he doesn't want the
government taking over the economy he
doesn't want a complete rear addict
already not in the economy the more the
Democrats talk about how they wants
radically reshift
how all of this works the more Democrats
talk about how they want crisis politics
to become the norm the more people are
going to resist what needs to be done in
the here and now so I think even
Democrats should probably be grateful
that a Republican is president right now
because whether you like Trump or not
the fact is that if you want people to
lock down they have to trust the
leadership is not what like people have
talked about I don't trust Trump to
handle this thing I think he's
incompetent I think he's a blowhard fine
but there's one thing that most
Americans do trust Trump with and that
is that he doesn't have the desire to
watch the government completely take
over American life and that is not
something that most Americans think I
think about Democrats I think that if
Barack Obama or Hillary Clinton or Joe
Biden were president right now and
talking about radically reshaping the
nature of the American economy
the blowback would be a lot more severe
the
the attempts to avoid the sort of
necessaries here would be a lot more
severe and it would be half right in
half wrong and be wrong because you got
to pay attention to the social
distancing and you got I mean we're
doing it in my house right you got to
pay attention to all of this stuff you
got to follow the best advice you got to
stop the spread and all of the rest but
at the same time they'd be half right in
in being a lot more impatient about how
this thing has gone so I'm gonna be
consistent I'm very impatient with how
this thing is going I want the data and
I want it now okay time for some things
I like and then some things that I hate
so things that I like right now is a
time where you're just stuck inside
watching kids movies as I've mentioned
there's a great kids movie that just
came out it's been really underrated
because it came out like right directly
before the virus hit and shut down all
the theaters but the last 30 minutes of
this thing are just a killer it's onward
by Pixar and it wasn't rated super
highly by critics like it did it did
well with critics but they were like oh
this isn't in the top tier of Pixar
films there are some moments in this
that are on par with with some of the
best stuff in OP they're really some
really good stuff here so this is the
movie is onward it's about basically
para brothers who are elves and their
dad died a while ago and they are able
to bring him back for a day but they
screw up the spell they're unable to
actually bring his entire body back and
so they only bring back his legs
basically and so they have to go on a
quest to bring back the rest of their
dad before the day ends and he could
only come back for the day so it's
pretty it's actually pretty pretty
emotional here's a little bit of a
trailer
hi missus legs I remember having a top
part Oh what did I do
hi we only have 24 hours to bring the
rest of him back until then hey Dad you
look just like I remember
[Music]
you want a problem shame
adventure you see
you come to the right govern
oh so the movies actually really fun
there's there's a lot to it and it's
it's fairly it's fairly deep so it's
it's definitely worth checking out and
one thing about Pixar is again when you
watch the movies with your kids you're
enjoying it on one level they're
enjoying it on another and it's and it's
pretty great okay time for some things
that I hate so as I mentioned one of the
things that the Democrats are trying to
do here and it really is pretty gross is
that they are trying to mix two messages
message number one is that Trump is bad
at this and incompetent and message
number two is that we need a permanent
reshaping of the relationship between
government and the American people so
that's hard to do while Trump is
president because on the one hand you're
saying he's incompetent and on the other
hand you're saying you should take
ultimate power over everybody's destiny
and that's a really hard message so
instead what they have said is he's
incompetent if you were confident things
would be great which is why when you
give us power we're gonna take over
everything and then we'll be competent
and then everything will be right now as
I've pointed out everybody was getting
this wrong for like weeks on end right
like everybody was getting this wrong
for a very long time and then in early
March when the testing started to ramp
up and it started to become clear what
exactly was happening then everybody
started to take this a lot more
seriously and that is because failures
of information exist on the private
level they exist in the public level I
mean the testing information as of late
February was was pretty nebulous I was
saying that there wasn't a lot of
evidence that a pandemic was in the
offing like late February and I was
saying that because the testing
information at that point did not have
tons of evidence that a pandemic was in
the offing I said things could change
they did change a pandemic was in the
offing obviously the w-h-o had not
declared it a pandemic at that point so
when it comes to competence everybody
bright left Center is fairly equally
incompetent right everybody gets things
wrong but Democrats want to make the
case that government is uniquely good at
things it's just that Trump is uniquely
bad at things because if they say that
government is uniquely good at things
then people go wait but aren't you also
saying that the government is sucking
this up like being terrible and the
Democrats answer's no no if it weren't
for Trump government would be doing an
excellent job and that's why you're
seeing them point to Cuomo because Cuomo
keeps saying yeah sure like New York is
a hot spot and a hotbed and de Blasio
blew it in in City and my policies may
not have been all that great but Trump
but Trump but Trump is an all-purpose
defense for the
fact that government generally right
left and Sentra is not very good at
things right so they've been pushing
this dual message which is Trump is
incompetent and also we need to
radically reshift how things are done in
the United States so rahm emanuel the
the former obama chief of staff mayor of
chicago mayor of chicago he says that
this really is just a matter biden
versus trump is really just competence
versus incompetence is revealed
character and in many ways while you can
have a lot of different policies is
going to be the qualities of the
individual come forward and I think in
the contrast care and there's not just
because I'm a Democrat you have
competence versus incompetence you have
trustworthiness versus actually
constantly spin and you have actually
the most important quality which is the
ability of a president to be empathetic
to the people that they lead versus I
think something coming out of the White
House have been of Konza indifference
and constant conflict and fighting ok so
again its competence versus incompetence
there's only one problem the Democrats
have been incompetent on this all the
way through to again de Blasio was mayor
of New York the mayor of New Orleans was
telling people to go out and celebrate
Mardi Gras Nancy Pelosi in late February
was telling people they ought to go down
to Chinatown and hang out right like
they like the incompetence who runs
across the island if you want to say
that Joe Biden is supremely competent
again I'm not seeing the evidence on
this right like over the weekend Joe
Biden was criticizing Donald Trump for
being too slow on the China travel ban
in January who's ripping him as a
xenophobe for it right in in January Joe
Biden was saying that Trump never should
have had any sort of travel ban from
China for weeks he has been as guy
Benson says a town hall reactive
repeatedly almost comically recommending
courses of action the Trump
administration had already pursued or
implemented or on Friday the former VP
supported he actually turned and
supported Trump's January 31st decision
to ban foreign nationals suddenly Kate
Bedingfield Biden's deputy campaign
manager said science supported this ban
therefore Biden did to Joe Biden
supports travel bans that are guided by
medical experts advocated by public
health officials backed by a full
strategy he opposed the European travel
ban he opposed the China travel ban and
now he's trying to shift it and say oh
well you know it's just I was just upset
that Trump didn't do it sooner what the
living hell here is Joe Biden being
incompetent in proving the point
everybody's incompetent you have to move
swiftly and there we have to move more
rapidly
you have to remember implement the
defense production active power supply
supplied commander create a you know a
defense production act for banks that
could get out of small business loans
ramped up testing the whole range of
things got to go faster than slower and
we started off awfully slow you know
forty five nations had already moved to
keep blocked China's about personnel
from being able coming United States
before the president moved so it's just
it's about pace it's about it's about
the urgency and I don't think there's
been enough it switched it right he's
switching it he opposed it and now it's
like oh he didn't do it sooner right as
if Trump had said he wanted to ban
travel from China like early January m4
Biden would have been all over that okay
bottom line is incompetence is
bipartisan that's one thing you can
guarantee about human beings no matter
their industries they will make mistakes
but I mean speaking up in confidence by
the way and just sheer political
brazenness Biden over the weekend he was
ripping into Trump because the the
Defense Department fired this Navy
captain why because he decided to email
everybody on his email chain and say we
need to shut down this entire battle
carrier that's the reason he was fired
not because he was recommending up the
chain but they needed to control the
kovin situation on this battle carrier
but because he was emailing everybody
outside the chain of command you can't
do that you can't do that
if somebody even at my company okay
we're not the National Defense sector if
somebody at my company had a
recommendation for how the show could be
better and then they ran it up the chain
that's totally fine we do that all the
time here if that person then copied the
entire mainstream media and was like by
the way this place is a bleep show you
know what happened is that person they
get fired that's the way this works but
here's Joe Biden suggesting that it is
criminal how Trump was treating this
Navy captain I think it is I think it's
close to criminal the way they're
dealing with this guy not his not his
conduct the idea that this man stood up
and and said what had to be said got it
out that his his troops his his Navy
personnel were in danger in danger look
how many had the virus I think the guy
should be cut he should be have a
commendation rather than be fired hey he
should get a commendation for copying
people outside the chain of command it's
a very weird way to run a military okay
so the point here is that proof positive
competence not great across the aisle
and it comes to government but the
Democrats have a stake in claiming that
they are great a government why because
what they actually want is to transform
the relationship between Americans in
the government which should scare
everybody and again actually drives a
wedge in a time when we don't need a
wedge all right so you get Bernie who's
out there still and Biden is still
trying to capitulate to him here's
Bernie saying we still need fundamental
socialist change in the United States
you want to scare people into saying
okay screw all of us I'm going back out
and I'm working this is pretty much how
you do it younger people in this country
understand that we need fundamental
change in the structure of American
society and instead of having society
which glamorizes billionaires and says
that we're all in this the only thing
that we should be doing is trying to
make huge amounts of money there was an
entire younger generation that says well
you know what maybe we should work
together to create an economy that works
for all I healthcare system that works
for all okay so like that that's gonna
scare everybody because again the
argument the combined argument Trump's
incompetent therefore put Bernie or
Biden in charge and they're not only
going to fix this thing
and make sure there's no pandemic
they're gonna completely reshape how
American government is done it's pretty
astonishing by the way I just got to
point out this ironing Bernie Sanders
yesterday he says that Trump is gonna
cause thousands of people to die also do
you remember Bernie canceling any of his
rallies like February early March I do
not remember that do you because it
didn't happen also my favorite here is
that Bernie says that Trump is going to
hand out money to people to help his
reelection
does Bernie and I see the irony of being
a socialist claiming that somebody else
is going to hand out somebody else's
money in order to help their reelection
here's Bernie we have a president who
has done so much harm in this entire
process who has downplayed the crisis
from day one which will cost us that his
actions or inactions in not listening to
the scientists and spouting off
ridiculous ideas is in fact going to
cost the lives of many thousands of
Americans but if you think that during a
campaign you are not going to see a lot
of money from the Trump administration
going to battleground states -
Pennsylvania Michigan Wisconsin Florida
you
would be grossly under estimating the
venality reality of this president I'm
really enjoying Bernie Sanders
explaining that if you give people
checks that they are going to vote for
you I'm really enjoying that Bernie a
socialist claiming that he is above
reproach but his entire program is steal
money from some people and give it to
other people for their votes but it's
bad when Trump signs the checks because
everybody's unemployed all righty well
we'll be back here later today the two
additional hours of content and we'll
bring you some more experts we'll talk
to some doctors you know we're
constantly trying to bring you
information if you have a chance listen
to our Sunday special yesterday it was
really good we spoke to a couple of
different doctors one from University of
California San Francisco the other from
Hoover Institution we also spoke to
Mohamed el-erian from Allianz about the
economic fallout from all of this it's
really worth to listen so go check that
out otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
why douse key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by micro Romina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 you know the
Matt Walsh show it's not just another
show about about politics I think there
are enough of those already out there we
talk about culture because culture
drives politics and it drives everything
else so my main focus is our life family
faith those are fundamental and that's
what this show is about I hope you'll
give it a listen